[Music]
every year forbes scours the globe
looking for every billionaire on the
planet and this year even amid the war
in ukraine chinese tech crackdown and
markets that are struggling kind of all
around the globe we still found 2
68 billionaires they're worth a
collective 12.7 trillion dollars that's
with a t
uh which is an incredible amount of
money but actually 400 billion dollars
less than they were worth last year and
there are 87 fewer billionaires in the
world than last year there are a lot of
billionaires behind decacorn companies
which are companies that are valued at
at least 10 billion dollars it used to
be that if you were a
venture funded company and you hit a
billion dollars in valuation you were
called a unicorn and it was extremely
impressive and these days a billion
dollars is uh you know kind of not
enough the really impressive metric is
decacorns companies that are worth at
least 10 billion and we found something
like 30 uh decacorns and there are
billionaires behind a lot of those
another major trend with billionaires
this year is that oil and gas and energy
billionaires are doing extremely well i
mean you'd see high prices at the pump
the billionaires behind oil and gas are
just really thriving these days
global supply chain issues have made it
difficult to get all sorts of goods like
we all know and a lot of companies have
warned their investors that their bottom
lines might be impacted by these supply
chain issues but there's always someone
somewhere profiting no matter what's
going on in the world
and in this case it's shipping and
logistics companies who are really
having banner years and record profits
and that's adding billions of dollars to
the fortunes of the billionaires behind
those companies people like klaus
michael cuna and gm luigi and rafaela
aponte so despite everything that's
going on in the world
more than a thousand billionaires are
richer than they were a year ago
and no one got richer over the past year
than elon musk who tops the billionaires
list for the first time ever musk is
worth 219 billion dollars this year
which is 68 billion dollars more than he
was worth a year ago thanks to soaring
tesla stock
behind elon musk is jeff bezos who is
the second richest person in the world
with 171 billion dollars to his name
after bezos is bernard arneau who's
worth 158 billion then bill gates at
number four with 129 billion and warren
buffett is the fifth richest person in
the world this year worth 118 billion
dollars well there are a lot of
billionaires who are doing really well
there are some that are not doing so
well and you know one group of
billionaires that are in general not
doing very well would be russian
billionaires
so an oligarch generally refers to
people who are very wealthy business
people
who have some kind of political or
social influence when it comes to
to russia specifically
we often look at sort of two time
periods in which oligarchs
arose
one is the original oligarchs who made
their fortunes in the 1990s
during the very chaotic privatization
area after the collapse of the soviet
union
when a lot of state assets were
sold to
private investors on the cheap
especially through a now infamous
voucher system under president boris
yeltsin
and then there was sort of another wave
of oligarchs that arose after uh
vladimir putin rose to power in 2000 a
lot of the people in that group tended
to be
individuals who had close ties to putin
from the early 90s or even before then
and who were able to enrich themselves
thanks to their close ties to putin
generally right oligarch is people who
still have political influence but that
can also sort of refer to how they made
their fortune you know some some
original oligarchs from the 1990s then
fell out of favor actually when putin
was in power
but they were still oligarchs
[Music]
the war in ukraine has had a pretty
significant impact on the wealth of
oligarchs that we track it forms we
estimate that there's around 89
oligarchs in russia several of whom have
actually been sanctioned recently by our
estimates these oligarchs were worth a
collective 290 billion dollars on march
11 which is the date that we finalized
the valuations for our 2022 world
billionaires list and we estimate that
they've lost around 240 billion dollars
so nearly half of their pre-war network
since january before the war began so
the richest person in russia and also
the richest person we consider an
oligarch in russia is vladimir lisin and
we currently estimate his net worth
about 18.4 billion dollars
for context he was worth around 31
billion before the war began in january
better release lisa rose to to fame sort
of in in the 1990s when he was cutting
his teeth in the brutal aluminum wars
today lee sin draws his fortune from
the nlmk group which is a very large
manufacturer of steel products
so since the war began
several assets owned by
sanctioned russian millionaires and
oligarchs have been frozen that means
that these assets can no longer be used
by these individuals and they can't get
any economic benefit from them such as
selling them or renting them but they
still legally own them they have not
been seized by governments
in any of these countries
so we estimate that more than 23 billion
dollars in assets have been hit by
western sanctions since the beginning of
the war perhaps the most prominent
example is roman abramovich's english
premier league soccer team chelsea fc
which is being sold now and the british
government has said that none of the
proceeds will go to abramovic then
another great example is alisher usmanov
who has been sanctioned by the eu and
the uk and the u.s he owns an airbus
a340 300 jet which is blocked by the us
he also has a yacht that is made by
sanctions in germany it's the largest
yacht in the world and is among the at
least 1.5 billion dollars in yachts that
have been hit by western sanctions
he also owns several homes in the uk
which have been blocked by the british
government meaning that he cannot rent
them or sell them or because there's a
travel ban in place against him in the
uk he can't travel there either his
homes in the uk are part of the at least
2.4 billion dollars in real estate that
has been sanctioned so far by western
authorities it's very difficult even for
governments to
actually ascertain who owns these assets
several of these oligarchs simply
transferred ownership of their assets
such as real estate
to relatives or folks associates so as
long as these individuals are able to
get around the sanctions by
selling
certain stakes or transferring ownership
it's still difficult to see if this will
actually have an impact on them long
term of course they can no longer travel
to much of the west and it will be very
difficult for them to
invest in any asset in the west it's
still an open question whether it will
actually have an impact on their network